The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I guess we might as
well get started.
We talked a little bit about
Markov processes last week.
I want to review a little bit of
what we did then, and then
move on pretty quickly.
This is a rather strange
chapter, because
it's full of notation.
When I first started reviewing
it myself after not having
looked at it for about a year,
I was horrified by the amount
of notation.
And then I realized, what we're
doing in this chapter is
putting together all the
stuff we've learned
from Poisson processes.
There are Poisson processes
all through this
Markov chains renewals.
And all three of these, with
all their notation, are all
sitting here.
And then we get into new things,
also, so I apologize
for the notation.
I'm going to try to keep
it down to the
minimal amount this time.
And see if we can sort of get
to the bottom line as easily
as we can, so that when you do
the exercises and read the
notes, you can go back in
fill in some of the
things that are missing.
OK.
So accountable state
Markov process.
The easiest way to define it,
and the way we're defining it
is as an extension
of accountable
state Markov chain.
So you start out with
accountable state Markov
chain, and then along with each
step, say from state x
sub n to x sub n plus 1, there
is an exponential holding
time, u sub n plus 1.
We said that it was a little
strange associating the
holding time of the
final state rather
than the initial state.
But you almost had to do that,
because of many things that
would get very confusing
otherwise.
So we're just doing that.
We start out in state x0,
which is usually given.
If it's not given,
it can be random.
And then we go to state x1 after
a waiting time, u sub 1.
Go from x1 to x2 with a
waiting time u sub 2.
The waiting time u sub i is a
function of the state we're
coming from, in the sense that
it's an exponential random
variable who's rate is
given by the state
we're coming from.
So this diagram here gives
you, really, what the
dependence of this set of
random variables is.
You have a sequence of random
variables here.
A sequence of random
Each random variable here
conditional on the initial
state that it's coming
from, is independent
of everything else.
And that's what this dependence
diagram means.
It's a generalization of what
we talked about before.
When we talked about Markov
chains before, we just had a
string of states.
And each state x sub n is
dependent only on the prior
state x sub n minus 1.
And given the prior state
x sub n minus 1, it's
statistically independent of
all states before that.
Here we have this more general
situation of a tree.
I thought I'd better illustrate
this a little more.
If you have a directed tree, the
dependencies, each random
variable conditional as parent
is statistically independent
of all earlier random
variables.
In other words, this random
variable here conditional on
this random variable is
statistically independent of
this, this, this, and this.
And so you can move forward in
this way, defining each random
variable as being statistically
independent of
everything in the past,
conditional on just one
previous random variable.
As an example of this, if you
look at the probability of x0,
x1, x2, and u2, these five
random variables here.
Probability of x0, probability
of x1 given x0.
Probability of x2 given x1.
Probability of u2 given x1.
You can write that
out in that way.
From this, you can rewrite this
in any way you want to.
You take these two equations,
and you can rewrite them as a
probability of x1 times the
probability of x0 given x1,
times the probability of
x2 given x1, times the
probability u2 given x1.
In other words, what's happening
here is if you
condition everything on x1,
this random variable here,
this stuff is statistically
independent of this.
Is statistically independent
of all of this.
Given any one node in this
three, given the value of that
node, everything on every set of
branches coming out from it
is statistically independent.
This is a remarkably
useful property.
This is the Markov property
in general.
I mean, Markov chains,
we only use the fact
that it's on a chain.
In general you use the fact
that it's on a tree.
And all of this stuff can be
used in remarkable ways.
I didn't know this until
probably five years ago.
And suddenly when I realized it,
I think because somebody
was pointing it out
in a research
paper they were writing.
Suddenly all sorts of things
became much, much easier.
Because everything like the fact
we pointed out before,
that the past is independent
of the future, given the
present, that's one
example of this.
But this is far more
general than that.
It says that anything on this
tree, if you can start at any
point on the tree, and
everything going out from
there is statistically
independent, given this node
on the tree.
So that's a valuable thing.
And so you get your condition
on any node, breaks a tree
into independent sub trees.
You can then go on from there
and break it down further and
further and further, until you
get out to the leaves.
So this independence property
is really the general thing
that we refer to when we
say a set of random
variables are Markov.
OK.
The evolution in time with a
Markov process, this diagram I
find very helpful to
see what's going
on in a Markov process.
You have a set of states.
Initially, you're in a state
x0, the state at time 0 is
some given value i.
This is a sample path here.
The next state we'll say is
j, the next state is a k.
When you're in state i, there's
some holding time,
which has rate new
1, new sub i.
It's an exponential random
variable which tells you how
long it takes until
this transition.
This transition occurs
at time s1, which is
u1 is equal to s1.
The next transition is at s2.
Equals u1 plus u2.
The next transition is at x3,
which is u1 plus u2 plus u3.
Now you start to see why we've
numbered these holding times
the way we have, so we can talk
about the times that each
of these transitions
take place.
We usually assume that the
embedded Markov chain for a
Markov process, remember, the
embedded Markov chain now is
just the Markov chain
itself without these
holding times on it.
We assume it has no self
transitions because if you're
sitting in a state x of t equals
i, and suddenly there's
a transition back to i again,
and you look at the process in
terms of x of t, t greater
than or equal to 0.
The state that you're in at
each time t, what happens?
You don't see it.
It's a totally invisible
transition, because you're
sitting in state i.
You suddenly have a transition
back to i that takes 0 time.
So you stay in state i.
You can put that transition
in or you can take it out.
It doesn't make any
difference.
It won't affect the
process at all.
OK.
Aside from that issue of these
self transitions, a sample
path of both x sub n, each of
these x sub 0 equals i, x sub
1 equals j.
x sub 2 equals k.
A sample path as those plus the
holding times specifies
what x of t is at each
instant of time.
And if you know what x of t is
at each unit of time, that
tells you when the transitions
are occurring.
When you know when the
transitions are occurring, you
know what the these u's are.
And when you see what the
transition is into, you know
what the state is.
So the description of a Markov
process in terms of the
process, what we call a process
x sub t for all t
greater than or equal to 0,
and the set of random
variables, the embedded Markov
chain, and the holding times
are both equivalent
to each other.
This shouldn't be any surprise
to you by now, because every
process we've talked to,
we've talked about.
We've described in
the same way.
We described the Poisson process
in multiple ways.
We described Markov chains
We described renewal processes
in multiple ways.
And this is just another
example of that.
You use whatever description you
want to after you've shown
they're all equivalent.
So there's really nothing
new here.
Or is there?
Who can see what there is about
this relationship, which
is different from what we've
just been talking about?
It's using one extra property.
This is not just a consequence
of this, it also uses
something else.
And what else does it use?
What I'm doing is saying x of
t at this instance of time
here is dependent on given
x of t is some
previous time here.
The state here, given the state
here is independent of
everything in the past.
So what else am I using there?
I'm using the memory looseness
of the Poisson process.
I'm using the memory
looseness of the
exponential random variable.
If I'm given the state here,
and I'm conditioning on the
state here, this is
an exponential
random variable in here.
The time the next transition
is exponential
given this time here.
And it doesn't matter
when the previous
transition took place.
So if I'm given the state at
this time here, the time to
the next transition is an
exponential random variable,
the same distribution as u2.
So what this says is I'm using
the initial description in
terms of an embedded Markov
chain plus holding times, and
I'm adding to that the fact
that the holding times are
exponential, and therefore
they're memory less.
OK, that clear to everybody?
It's vitally important
for all of this.
Because it's hard to do anything
with Markov processes
without realizing explicitly
that you're using the fact
that these random variables
are memory less.
At the end of this chapter,
there's something called semi
Markov processes.
The description is that
semi Markov processes
are exactly the same.
Semi Markov chains are exactly
the same as markup processes
except, these holding times
are not exponential.
They can be anything.
And as soon as the holding times
can be anything, the
process gets so complicated that
you hardly want to talk
about it anymore.
So the fact that we have these
exponential holding times is
really important in terms of
getting this condition here,
which lets you talk directly
about the process, instead of
the embedded Markov chain.
You're going to represent a
Markov process by a graph for
the embedded Markov chain, and
then you give the rates on top
of the nodes.
So if you're in state 0, the
holding time until you enter
the next state is given as
some, the rate of that
exponential is given as new 0.
The rate here is given
as new 1, so forth.
Ultimately, we're usually
interested in this process, x
of t, t greater than or equal
to 0, which is the Markov
process itself.
x of t is equal to xn for t in
sub n, between sub n and
s sub n plus 1.
What does that mean?
Well, it means at this point,
we're taking the Markov
process as the fundamental
thing, and we're describing it
in terms of the nth
state transition.
But we know that the nth state
transition takes place at time
s sub n, namely it takes place
at the sum of all of these
exponential holding times
up until that point.
And that state stays there until
the next exponential
holding time.
So this really gives you the
linkage between the Markov
process in this expression,
and the markup process in
terms of this graphical
expression here with the
embedded chain, and the
exponential holding times.
OK.
You can visualize a transition
from one state to another in
tree very convenient ways.
And these are ways that we've, I
hope we've really learned to
think about from looking
at Poisson processes.
You can visualize this
transition by first using the
next state by these transition
probabilities in the embedded
Markov chain.
And then you choose a transition
time, which is
exponential with
rate new sub i.
Equivalently, because it's a
Poisson process, you can
choose the--
well, no, because these are
independent given the state.
You can choose the transition
time first, and then you can
choose the state, because these
are independent of each
other conditional on the
state that you're in.
And finally, equivalently, which
is where the Poisson
process comes in, a really neat
way to think of Poisson
processes is to have an
enormously large number of
Poisson processes running
all the time.
There's one Poisson process for
every transition in this
Markov chain.
So you have accountably infinite
number of Poisson
processes, which sounds a little
complicated at first.
But you visualize a Poisson
process for each state pair i
to j, which has a rate q sub ij,
which is the rate at which
transitions occur out of
state i times p sub ij.
This is the rate which, when
you're in state i, you will go
to state j.
And this makes use of all this
stuff about splitting and
combining Poisson processes.
If you have a Poisson process
which has rate new sub i and
you split it into a number of
Poisson processes, for each
next state you might go to,
you're splitting it into
Poisson processes of rate new
sub i times p sub ij.
And what's happening there is
there's a little switch.
The little switch has
probabilities p sub ij, and
that switch is telling you which
state to go to next.
All of this is totally
artificial.
And I hope by this time, you are
comfortable about looking
at physical things in a totally
artificial way,
because that's the magic
of mathematics.
If you didn't have mathematics,
you couldn't look
at real things in
artificial ways.
And all the science would
suddenly disappear.
So what we're doing here is
defining this Markov process
in this artificial way of all
of these little Poisson
processes, and we now know
how they all work.
When the entry to state i, the
next state is the j with an x
Poisson arrival, according
to q sub ij.
So all these Poisson processes
are waiting to have an
arrival come out.
To have a race, one of
them wins, and you
go off to that state.
OK, question.
What's the conditional
distribution of u1 given that
x0 i, and x1 equals j?
And to imagine this, suppose
that there are only two places
you can go from state 0.
You can go into state 1
with some very large
probability, say 0.999.
Or you can go into state 2 with
some very, very small
probability.
And what that means is this
exponential random variable
going from state 0 into state
2 is a very, very
slow, random variable.
It has a very small rate.
And the exponential random
variable going into state 1 is
a very, very large
random variable.
So you would think that if you
go from state 0 the state x2,
it means it must take a very
long time to get there.
Well, that's absolutely wrong.
The time that it takes to go
from x0 to x2 is this random
variable, u sub i.
Where u sub i is the state you
happen to be in at this point
when you're in--
x0 is the state that
we start in.
x0 is a random variable.
It has some value i.
With this value i, there's an
exponential random variable
that determines how long
it takes you to
get to the next state.
This random variable conditional
on x0 equals i is
independent of which state
you happen to go to.
And what that means is that the
conditional distribution
of u1, given x sub 0 is equal
to i, and x sub 1 equals j.
If you've had your ears at all
open for the last 10 minutes,
it is exponential with rate i.
With rate new sub i.
These holding times and the
next states you go to are
independent of each other,
conditional on where you
happen to be.
It's the same thing we saw back
in Poisson processes.
It was confusing as
hell back then.
It is still confusing as hell.
If you didn't get it sorted out
in your mind then, go back
and think about it again now,
and try to get your common
sense, which tells you when
you go to state 2, it must
take a long time to get there,
because that exponential
random variable has a very
long holding time.
And that just isn't true.
And it wasn't true when we were
dealing with a Poisson
process, which got
split either.
These two things are independent
of each other.
Intuitively, why that is, I
almost hesitate to try to say
why it is, because it's such
a tricky statement.
If you happen to go to state 2
instead of to state 1, what's
happening is that all of this
time that you're waiting to
have a state transition, when
you finally have this state
transition, you then flip a
switch to see which state
you're going to go to.
And the fact that it's taken you
a long time to get there
says nothing whatsoever about
what this switch is doing,
because that switch is
independent of how long it
takes you for the switch
to operate.
And I know.
It's not entirely intuitive,
and you just have to beat
yourself on the head until
it becomes intuitive.
I've beaten myself on
the head until I can
hardly think straight.
It still isn't intuitive to me,
but maybe it will become
intuitive to you.
I hope so.
So anyway, this gives the
conditional distribution of u1
given that x0 is equal to i,
and x1 is equal to-- no.
This says that the exponential
rate out of state i is equal
to the sum of the exponential
rates to each of the states we
might be going to.
We have to go to some
other state.
We have no self transitions as
far as we're concerned here.
Even if we had self transitions,
this formula
would still be correct, but
it's easier to think of it
without self transitions.
p sub ij, this is the
switch probability.
It's q sub ij divided
by new sub i.
This is the probability you're
going to go to j given that
you were in state i.
The matrix of all of these cues
specifies the matrix of
all of these p's, and
it specifies new.
That's what this formula says.
If I know what q is, I know what
new is, I know what p is.
And we've already said that if
you know what p is and you
know what new is, you know
what q sub ij is.
So these are completely
equivalent representations of
the same thing.
You can work with either
one you want to.
Sometimes one is useful,
sometimes the other is useful.
If you look at an mm1q,
mm1q, you remember,
is exponential arrivals.
Exponential service time.
The time of the service is
independent of when it
happens, or who it happens to.
These service times are just
individual exponential random
variables of some rate mu.
The arrivals are the
inter-arrival intervals are
exponential random variables
of rate lambda.
So when you're sitting in state
0, the only place you
can is to state one.
You're sitting there, and
if you're in state 0,
the server is idle.
You're waiting for the first
arrival to occur.
The next thing that happens has
to be an arrival because
it can't be a service.
So the transition here is
with probability 1.
All these other transitions are
with probability lambda
divided by lambda plus mu,
because in all of these other
states, you can get an arrival
or a departure.
Each of them are exponential
random variables.
The switch probability that
we're talking about is in
lambda over lambda
plus mu to go up.
Mu over lambda plus mu
to go down for all
states other than 0.
If you write this, this
is in terms of the
embedded Markov chain.
And if you write this in
terms of the transition
probabilities, it
looks like this.
Which is simpler?
Which is more transparent?
Well this, really, is
what the mm1q is.
That's where we started
when we started
talking about mm1q's.
This in this situation is
certainly far simpler.
You're giving these transition
probabilities.
But don't forget that we still
have this embedded Markov
chain in the background.
Both these graphs have
the same information.
Both these graphs have the same
information for every
Markov process you want
to talk about OK.
Let's look at sample time
approximations to Markov processes.
And we already did it
in the last chapter.
We just didn't talk about
it quite so much.
We quantized time to increments
of delta.
We viewed all Poisson processes
in a Markov process.
Remember, we can view all
of these transitions as
independent Poisson processes
all running
away at the same time.
We can view all of these Poisson
processes as Bernoulli
processes with probability of
a transition from i to j in
the increment delta, given as
a delta times qij, to first
order in delta.
So we can take this Markov
process, turn it into a rather
strange kind of Bernoulli
process.
For the M/M/1 queue, all that's
doing is turning into a
sample time, M/M/1 process.
And we can sort of think
the same way about
general Markov processes.
We'll see when we can
and when we can't.
Since shrinking Bernoulli goes
to Poisson, we would
conjecture the limiting Markov
chain as delta goes to 0 goes
through a Markov process.
In a sense that X of t is
approximately equal to X prime.
This is X prime as in
the Bernoulli domain
at delta times n.
You have to put self-transition
into a sample
time approximation.
Because if you have a very small
delta, there aren't big
enough transition probabilities
going out of the
chain to fill up the
probability space.
So in most transition, you're
going to just have a
self-transition.
So you need a self-transition,
which is 1 minus delta times
nu sub i, and these transitions
to other states,
which are delta times
q sub ij.
This has the advantage that if
you believe this, you can
ignore everything we're saying
about Poisson processes
because you already
know all of it.
We already talked about
sample time processes.
You can do this for any
old process almost.
And when you do this for any old
process, you're turning it
into a Markov change instead
of a Markov process.
This is the same argument you
tried to use when you were a
senior in high school or
freshman in college when you
said, I don't have to learn
calculus, because all it is is
just taking increments
to be very small and
looking at a limit.
So I will just ignore
all that stuff.
It didn't work there.
It doesn't work here.
But it's a good thing to go
every time you get confused,
because this you can sort
out for yourself.
There is one problem here.
When you start making shrieking
delta more and more,
if you want to get a sample time
approximation, delta has
to be smaller than 1 over the
maximum of the nu sub i's.
If it's not smaller than the
maximum of the nu sub i's, the
self-transition probability
here is
unfortunately negative.
And we don't like negative
probabilities.
So you can't do that.
If you have a Markov process,
has a countably infinite
number of states, each of these
nu sub i's are positive.
But they can approach
0 as a limit.
As if they approach 0 as a
limit, you cannot describe a
sample time Markov chain to go
with the Markov process.
All you can do is truncate
the chain also and
then see what happens.
And that's often a good
way to do it.
OK, so we can always do this
sample time approximation.
What is nice about the sample
time approximation is that we
will find it in general, if you
could use the sample time
approximation, it always gives
you the exact steady state
probabilities.
No matter how crude you are in
this approximation, you always
wind up with the exact rate
values when you're all done.
I don't know why.
We will essentially prove
today that that happens.
But that's a nice thing.
But it doesn't work with the nu
sub i's approach 0, because
then you can't get
a sample time
approximation to start with.
OK, let's look at the embedded
chain model in the sample time
model of M/M/1 queue.
I hate to keep coming back
to the M/M/1 queue.
But for Markov processes,
they're all so similar to each
other that you might as well
get very familiar with one
particular model of them,
because that one particular
model tells you most of the
distinctions that you have to
be careful about.
Let's see.
What is this?
This is the embedded chain
model that we've
talked about before.
When you're in state 0,
the only place you can
go is to state 1.
When you're in state 1, you
can go down with some
probability.
You can go up with
some probability.
And since these probabilities
have to add up to 1, it's mu
over lambda plus mu and lambda
over lambda plus mu, and the
same thing forever after.
If we're dealing with the sample
time model, what we
wind up with is we start
out with qij,
which is lambda here.
The time it takes to get from
state 0 to make a transition,
the only place you can make a
transition to is state 1.
You make those transitions
at rate lambda.
So the sample time model has
this transition and discrete
time with probability lambda
delta, this transition with
probability mu delta
and so forth up.
You need these self-transitions
in order to
make things add up correctly.
The steady state for the
embedded chain is pi sub 0
equals 1 minus rho over 2.
How do I know that?
You just have to use
algebra for that.
But it's very easy.
I'm going to have to get
three of these things.
OK, any time you have a
birth-death chain, you can
find the steady state
probabilities.
The probability of going this
way is equal to the
probability of going this way.
If you add in the probability
of the steady state that
you're concerned with, steady
state transition this way, the
same as the probability
of a steady state
transition this way.
And you remember, the reason for
this is in a birth-death
chain, the total number of
transitions from here to here
has to be within 1 of the number
of transitions from
here to there.
So that if steady state
means anything--
and if these of long-term sample
space probabilities
with probability 1
mean anything--
this has to be true.
So when you do that, this
is what you get here.
This is a strange 1
minus rho over 2.
It's strange because of this
strange probability one here,
and this strange probability mu
over lambda plus mu here.
And otherwise, everything is
symmetric, so it looks the
same as this one here.
For this one, the steady state
for the sample time doesn't
depend on delta.
And it's pi sub i prime equals 1
minus rho times rho to the i
where rho equals
lambda over mu.
This is what we did before.
And what we found is since
transitions this way have to
equal transitions this way,
these self-transitions don't
make any difference here.
And you get the same answer
no matter what delta is.
And therefore you have pretty
much a conviction, which can't
totally rely on, that you can go
to the limit as delta goes
to 0 and find out what is going
on in the actual Markov
process itself.
You'll be very surprised with
this result if this were not
the result for steady state
probabilities in some sense
for the Markov process.
However, the embedded chain
probabilities and these
probabilities down here
are not the same.
What's the difference
between them?
For the embedded chain, what
you're talking about is the
ratio of transitions
that go from one
state to another state.
When you're dealing with the
process, what you're talking
about is the probability that
you will be in one state.
If when you get in one state
you stay there for a long
time, because the rate of
transitions out of that state
is very small, so you're going
to stay there for a long time.
That enhances the probability
of being in that state.
You see that right here,
because pi 0 is 1
minus rho over 2.
And pi 0 prime is 1 minus rho.
It's bigger.
And it's bigger because you're
going to stay there longer,
because the rate of getting out
of there is not as big as
it was before.
So the steady state
probabilities in the embedded
chain and the steady state
probabilities and the sample
time approximation
are different.
And the steady state
probabilities and the sample
time approximation are the same,
when you go to the limit
of infinitely fine
sample time.
Now what we have to do is go
back and look at renewal
theory and all those that and
actually convince ourselves
that this works.
OK, so here we have renewals
for Markov processes.
And what have we done so far?
We've been looking at
the Poisson process.
We've been looking
at Markov chains.
And we've been trying to refer
to this new kind of process.
Now we bring in the last
actor, renewal theory.
And as usual, Poisson processes
gives you the easy
way to look at a problem.
Markov chains gives you a way
to look at the problem, when
you'd rather write equations
and think about it.
And we renewal theory gives
you the way to look at the
problem when you really are a
glutton for punishment, and
you want to spend a lot of
time thinking about it.
And you don't want to write any
equations, or you don't
want to write many equation.
OK, an irreducible Markov
process is a Markov process
for which the embedded Markov
chain is irreducible.
Remember that an irreducible a
Markov chain is one where all
states are in the same class.
We saw that irreducible Markov
chains when we had a countably
infinite number of states, that
they could be transient,
the state simply wanders
off with high
probability, never to return.
If you have an M/M/1 queue,
and the expect the service
time is bigger than the
expected time between
arrivals, then gradually
the queue builds up.
The queue keeps getting longer
and longer as time goes on.
There isn't any steady state.
Looked at another way, the
steady state probabilities are
always 0, if you want to
just calculate them.
So we're going to see the
irreducible Markov processes
can have even more bizarre
behavior than these Markov
chains can.
And part of that more bizarre
behavior is infinitely many
transitions in a finite time.
I mean, how do you talk about
steady state when you have an
infinite number of transitions
and a finite time?
I mean, essentially, the
Markov process is
blowing up on you.
Transitions get more
and more frequent.
They go off to infinity.
What do you do after that?
I don't know.
I can write these equations.
I can solve these equations.
But they don't mean anything.
In other words sometimes,
talking about steady state, we
usually write equations
for steady state.
But as we saw with countable
state Markov chains, steady
state doesn't always
exist there.
There it evidenced itself with
steady state probabilities
that were equal to 0, which
said that as time went on,
things just got very diffused
or things wandered off to
infinity or something
like that.
Here it's this much worse thing,
where in fact you get
an infinite number of
transitions very fast.
And we'll see how that happens
a little later.
You might have a transition
rate which goes down to 0.
The process is chugging along
and gets slower, and slower,
and slower, and pretty soon
nothing happens anymore.
Well, always something happens
if you wait long enough, but
as you wait longer and
longer, things happen
more and more slowly.
So we'll see all of these
things, and we'll see
how this comes out.
OK, let's review briefly
accountable
state Markov chains--
an irreducible, that means
everything can talk to
everything else; is positive
recurrent if and only if the
steady state equations, pi sub
j equals the sum of pi
sub i, p sub ij.
Remember what this is.
If you're in steady state, the
probability of being in a
state j is supposed
to be pi sub j.
The probability of being in a
state is supposed to be equal
then to the sum of the
probabilities of being in
another state and going
to that state.
That's the way it has to
be if you're going to
have a steady state.
So this is necessary.
The pi sub j's have to be
greater than or equal to 0.
And the sum of the pi sub
j's is equal to 1.
It has a solution.
If this has a solution, it's
unique, and if pi sub i is
greater than 0 for all i, if
it's positive recurrent.
We saw that if it wasn't
positive recurrent, other
things could happen.
Also the number of visits, n
sub ij of n, remember in a
Markov chain, what we talked
about when we used renewal
theory was the number of visits
over a particular
number transitions
from i to j.
n sub ij of n is the number
of times we hit j's
in the first n trials.
I always do this.
Please take that n sub ij of n
and write 1 over n times n sub
ij of n is equal to pi j.
You all know that.
I know it too.
I don't know why it always gets
left off of my slides.
Now, we guessed for a Markov
process the fraction of time
in state j should be p sub j
equals pi sub j over a nu sub
j divided by the sum over i
of pi sub i over nu sub i.
Perhaps I should say I guessed
that because I
already know it.
I want to indicate to you why
if you didn't know anything
and if you weren't suspicious
by this time, you would make
that guess, OK?
We had this embedded
Markov chain.
Over a very long period
of time, the number of
transitions into state i is
going to be the number of
transitions into state i
divided by n is going
to be pi sub i.
That's what this equation here
says, or what it would say if
I had written it correctly.
Now, each time we get to pi
sub i, we're going to stay
there for a while.
The holding time in state
i is proportional to
1 over nu sub i.
The rate of the next transition
is nu sub i.
So the expected holding time is
going to be 1 over nu sub
i, which says that the fraction
of time that we're
actually in state i should be
proportional to the number of
times we go into state j times
the expected holding
time in state j.
Now when you write p sub j
equals pi sub j over nu sub j,
you have a constant there
which is missing.
Because what we're doing is
we're amortizing this over
some long period of time.
And we don't know what the
constant of amortization is.
But these probability
should add up to 1.
If life is at all fair to us,
the fraction of time that we
spent in each state j should be
some number which adds up
to 1 as we sum over j.
So this is just a normalization
factor that you
need to make the p sub
j's sum up to 1.
Now what this means physically,
and why it appears
here, is something we have to go
through some more analysis.
But this is what we
would guess if we
didn't know any better.
And in fact, it's pretty
much true.
It's not always true, but
it's pretty much true.
So now let's use renewal
theory to actually see
what's going on.
And here's where we need a
little more notation even.
Let n sub i of t be the number
of transitions between 0 and t
for a Markov process starting
in state i.
I can't talk about the number of
transitions if I don't say
what state we start in, because
then I don't really
have a random variable.
I could say let's start and
steady state, and that seems
very, very appealing.
I've tried to do that many
times, because it would
simplify all these theorems.
And it just doesn't
work, believe me.
So let's take the extra pain
of saying let's start
in some state i.
We don't know what it is, but
we'll just assume there is
some state.
And the theorem says that the
limit of M sub i of t is equal
to infinity.
Here I don't have a 1 over
t in front of it.
I've written incorrectly.
And this is a very technical
theorem.
We proved the same kind of
technical theorem when we were
talking about Markov chains,
if you remember.
We were talking about
Markov chains.
We said that in some sense, an
infinite number of transitions
into each one of the states
had to occur.
The same kind of proof
is the proof here.
It had the same kind of proof
when we were talking about
renewal theory.
What is going on is given any
state, given the state the
transition has to occur within
finite time, because there
some exponential holding
time there.
So the expected amount of time
for the next transition is 1
over nu sub i.
And that's finite for every
i in the chain.
And therefore, as you go from
one state to another, as the
frog those jumping from one lily
pad to another, and each
lily pad that it jumps on
there's some expected time
before it moves, and therefore
assuming that it keeps moving
forever and doesn't die, which
is what we assume with these
Markov chains, it will
eventually go through an
infinite number of steps.
And the proof of that
is in the text.
But it's exactly the same proof
as you've seen several
times before for renewal process
in countable state
Markov chains.
Next theorem is to say let M sub
ij of t be the number of
transitions to j, starting
in state i.
We can't get rid of the
starting state.
Somehow we have to
keep it in there.
We have some confidence that
it's not important, that it
shouldn't be there.
And we're going to see it
disappear very shortly.
But we have to keep it there
for the time being.
So if the embedded chain is
recurrent, then n sub ij of t
is a delayed renewal process.
And we sort of know that.
Essentially, transitions
keep occurring.
So renewals in the state
j must keep occurring.
And therefore, any time you go
to state j, the amount of time
that it takes until you get
there again, is finite.
We're not selling it to expect
at time is finite.
Expect time might be infinite.
We'll see lots of cases
where it is.
But you've got to get
there eventually.
That's the same kind of thing we
saw for renewal theory when
we had renewals and the things
that could happen eventually
they did happen.
I don't know whether any of
you are old enough to have
heard about Murphy's Law.
Murphy was an Irish
American to whom
awful things kept happening.
And Murphy's Law says that
if something awful
can happen, it will.
This says if this can happen,
eventually it will happen.
It doesn't say it will
happen immediately.
But it says it will
happen eventually.
You can think of this as
Murphy's Law, if you want to,
if you're familiar with that.
So we want to talk about steady
state for irreducible
Markov processes.
Now, let p sub j of i be the
time average fraction of time
in state j for the delayed
renewal process.
Remember we talked about p sub
j in terms of these sample
time Markov change.
And we talked about them a
little bit in terms of
imagining how long you would
stay in state j if you were in
some kind of steady state.
Here we want to talk
about p sub j of i.
In terms of strong law of
large numbers kinds of
results, we want to look at the
sample path average and
see the convergence with
probability one.
OK, so p sub j of i is a time
average fraction of time in
state j for the delayed
renewal process.
Remember we said that delay
renewal processes were really
the same as renewal processes.
You just had this first renewal,
which really didn't
make any difference.
And so p sub j of i is going
to be the limit as t
approaches infinity of the
reward that we pick up forever
of being in state j.
You get one unit of reward
whenever you're in state j, 0
units when you're
anywhere else.
So this is the time average
fraction of time
you're in state j.
This is divided by t.
And the assumption is
you start in time i.
So that affects this
a little bit.
The picture here says whenever
you go to state j, you're
going to stay in state j for
some holding time U sub n.
Then you go back to 0 reward
until the next time you went
to state j.
Then you jump up
to reward of 1.
You stay there for your holding
time until you get
into some other state, a
and that keeps going
on forever and ever.
What does the delayed renewal
reward theorem say?
It says that the expected reward
over time is going to
be the expect to reward in one
renewal divided by the
expected length of
the renewal path.
It says it's going to be
expected value of U sub n
divided by the expected time
that you stay in state j.
So it's 1 over nu sub j times
the expected time
you're in a state j.
That's a really neat result
that connects this steady
state probability.
Excuse my impolite computer.
This relates to fraction of time
you're in state i to the
expected delay in state j.
It's one of those maddening
things where you say that's
great, but I don't know how to
find either of those things.
So we go on.
We will find them.
And what we will find
is W sub j.
If we can find W sub j, we'll
also know p sub j.
M sub ij of t is delayed
renewal process.
The strong law for renewal says
the limit as t approaches
infinity of Mi j of t over t is
1 over this waiting time.
This is the number of
renewals you have
as t goes to infinity.
This is equal to 1 over the
expected length of that
renewal period.
Great.
So we take the limit as
t goes to infinity.
Of mij of t over mi of t.
This is the number of
transitions overall up to time
t starting in state i.
This is the number of those
transitions which
go into state j.
How do I talk about that?
Well, this quantity up here is
the number of transitions into
state j over the number of
transition that take place.
n sub ij of t is the number of
transitions out of total
transitions.
mi of t is the total number
of transitions.
mi of t goes to infinity.
So this limit here goes to the
limit of n sub ij of n over n.
Remember, we even proved this
very carefully in class for
the last application of it.
This is something we've done
many times already in
different situations.
And this particular time we're
doing it, we won't go through
any fuss about it.
It's just a limit of n
sub ij of n over n.
And what is that?
That's the fraction, long term
fraction of transitions that
go into state j.
We know that for accountable
state Markov chain, which is
recurrent, which is positive
recurrent, this is
equal to pi sub j.
So we have that as equal
to pi sub j.
We then have one over w sub j,
that's what we're trying to
find is equal to the limit of
mij, of t over t, which is the
limit of mij of t over mi of
t times mi of t over t.
We break this into a limit of
two terms, which we've done
very carefully before.
And this limit here
is pi sub j.
This limit here is the limit
of m sub i of t.
And we have already shown that
the limit of n sub i
of t is equal to--
Somewhere we showed that.
Yeah.
1 over w sub j is equal
to pj times new sub j.
That's what we proved right
down here. p sub j of i is
equal to 1 over new sub
j times w sub j.
Except now we're just calling
it p sub j because we've
already seen it.
Doesn't depend on i at all.
So one over w sub j is equal
to p sub j times new sub j.
This says if we know what
w sub j is, we know
what p sub j is.
So it looks like we're not
making any progress.
So what's going on?
OK, well let's look at this
a little more carefully.
This quantity here is a
function only of i.
1 over w sub j, over p sub
j and new sub j is a
function only of j.
Everything else in this
equation is a
function only of j.
That says that this quantity
here is independent of i, and
it's also independent of j.
And what is it?
It's the rate at which
transitions occur.
Overall transitions.
If you're in steady state, this
says that looking at any
state j, the total number of
transitions that occur is
equal to, well, I do it
on the next page.
So let's goes there.
It says that p sub j is equal
to 1 over new sub j.
w sub j is equal to pi j over
new j times this limit here.
OK.
So in fact, we now have a way
of finding p sub j for all j
if we can just find this
one number here.
This is independent of i, so
this is just one number, which
we now know is something that
approaches some limit with
probability one.
So we only have one unknown
instead of this countably
infinite number of unknowns.
Seems like we haven't really
made any progress, because
before, what we did was to
normalize these p sub js.
We said they have to add up to
1, and let's normalize them.
And here we're doing
the same thing.
We're saying p sub j is equal
to pi sub j over new sub j
with this normalization
factor in.
And we're saying here that this
normalization factor has
to be equal to 1 over the
sum of pi k over new k.
In other words, if the p sub
j's add to 1, then the only
value this didn't have is
1 over the sum of pi k
times new sub k.
Unfortunately, there are
examples where the sum of pi
sub k over new sub k is
equal to infinity.
That's very awkward.
I'm going to give you an example
of that in just a
minute, and you'll see
what's going on.
But if pi sub k over new sub k
is equal to infinity, and the
theorem is true, it says that
the limit of mi of t over t is
equal to 1 over infinity,
which says it's zero.
So what this is telling us is
what we sort of visualize
before, but we couldn't
quite visualize it.
It was saying that either these
probabilities add up to
1, or if they don't add up to 1,
this quantity here doesn't
make any sense.
This is not approaching
a limit.
The only way this can approach,
well, this can
approach a limit where
the limit is 0.
Because this theorem holds
whether it approaches the
limit or not.
So it is possible for
this limit to the 0.
In this case, these p
sub js are all 0.
And we've seen this kind
of thing before.
We've seen that on a Markov
chain, all the steady state
probabilities can be equal to
zero, and that's a sign that
we're either in a transient
condition, or in a null
recurrent position.
Namely, the state just wonders
away, and over the long term,
each state has 0 probability.
And that looks like the same
kind of thing which is
happening here.
This looks trivial.
There's a fairly long proof
in the notes doing this.
The only way I can find to do
this is to truncate the chain,
and then go to the limit as
the number of states gets
larger and larger.
And when you do that, this
theorem becomes clear.
OK, let's look at an example
where the sum of pi k over new
k is equal to infinity, and
see what's going on.
Visualize something
like an mm1 queue.
We have arrivals, and
we have a server.
But as soon as the queue starts
building up, the server
starts to get very rattled.
And as the server gets more and
more rattled, it starts to
make more and more mistakes.
And as the queue builds up also,
customers come in and
look at the queue, and say I'll
come back tomorrow when
the queue isn't so long.
So we both have this situation
where as the queue is building
up, service is getting slower
and the arrival rate is
getting slower.
And we're assuming here to make
a nice example that the
two of them build up in
exactly the same way.
So that's what's
happening here.
The service rate when there's
one customer being served is 2
to the minus 1.
The service right rate when
there are two customers in the
system is 2 to the minus 2.
The service rate when there
are three customers in the
system is 2 to the minus 3.
For each of these states, we
still have these transition
probabilities for the
embedded chain.
And the embedded chain, the only
way to get from here to
here is with probability 1,
because that's the only
transition possible here.
We assume that from state 1,
you go to states 0 with
probability 0.6.
You go to state two with
probability 0.4.
With state 1, from state 2,
you go up with probability
0.4, you go down with
probability 0.6.
The embedded chain
looks great.
There's nothing wrong
with that.
That's a perfectly stable mm1
queue type of situation.
It's these damned holding
times which become very
disturbing.
Because if you look at pi sub
j, which is supposed to be 1
minus rho times rho to the j.
Rho is 2/3, it's
lambda over mu.
So it's lambda over lambda
plus mu over rho
plus lambda plus mu.
It's 0.4 divided by
0.6, which is 2/3.
If we look at pi sub j over new
sub j, it's equal to 2 to
the j times 1 minus rho,
times rho to the j.
It's 1 minus rho times
4/3 to the j.
This quantity gets bigger and
bigger as j increases.
So when you try to
sum pi i over new
sub j, you get infinity.
So what's going on?
None of the states here have
an infinite holding time
associated with them.
It's just that the expected
holding time
is going to be infinite.
The expected number of
transitions over a long period
of time, according to this
equation here, expected
transitions per unit
time is going to 0.
As time goes on, you keep
floating back to state 0, as
far as the embedded chain
is concerned.
But you're eventually going to
a steady state distribution,
which is laid out over
all the states.
That steady state distribution
looks very nice.
That's 1 minus rho times
rho to the j.
Rho is 2/3, so the probability
of being in state j is going
down exponentially
as j gets big.
But the time that you spend
there is going up
exponentially even faster.
And therefore, when we sum all
of these things up, the
overall expected rate is equal
to zero, because the sum of
the pi j over new j is
equal to infinity.
OK.
So this is one of the awful
things that are going to
happen with Markov processes.
We still have an
embedded chain.
The embedded chain
can be stable.
It can have a steady state, but
we've already found that
the fraction of time in a state
is not equal to the
fraction of transitions that go
into that state. pi sub j
is not in general equal
to p sub j.
And for this example here with
the rattled server and the
discouraged customers, the
amount of time that it takes,
the expected amount of time that
it takes for customers to
get served is going to zero.
Even though the queue
was saying stable.
Does mathematics lie?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I've looked at this often enough
with great frustration,
but I believe it
at this point.
If you don't believe it, take
this chain here and truncate
it, and solve the problem for
the truncated chain, and then
look at what happens
as you start adding
states on one by one.
What happens as you start adding
states on one by one is
that the rate at which this
Markov process is serving
things is going to zero.
So the dilemma as the number
of states becomes infinite,
the rate at which things
happen is equal to 0.
It's not pleasant.
It's not intuitive.
But that's what it is.
And that can happen.
Again, let's go back to the
typical case of a positive
recurrent embedded chain, where
this funny sum here is
less than infinity.
If the sum here is less than
infinity, then you can
certainly express p sub j as
pi sub j over new sub j
divided by the sum over k of
p sub k over new sub k.
Why can I do that?
Because that's what
the formula says.
I don't like to live with
formulas, but sometimes things
get so dirty, the mathematics
play such awful tricks with
you that you have to live with
the formulas, and just try to
explain what they're doing.
p sub j is equal to this.
Limit of the service rate, if
this quantity is non infinite,
then things get churned
out of this queueing
system at some rate.
And the p sub js can
be solved for.
And this is the way
to solve for them.
OK, so that's pretty neat.
It says that if you can solve
the embedded chain, then you
have a nice formula for finding
the steady state
probabilities.
And you have a theorem which
says that so long as this
quantity is less than infinity
with probability one, the
fraction of time that you
stay in state j is
equal to this quantity.
Well, that's not good enough.
Because for the mm1 queue, we
saw that it was really a pain
in the neck to solve for the
steady state equations for the
embedded chain.
Things looked simpler for
the process itself.
So let's see if we can get those
equations back also.
What we would like to do is
to solve for the p sub j's
directly by using the steady
state embedded equation.
Embedded equations say that pi
sub j is equal to the sum over
i, pi sub i times p sub ij.
The probability of going into
a state is equal to the
probability of going
out of a state.
If I use this formula here, pi
sub j over new sub j divided
by some constant is
what p sub j is.
So pi sub j is equal to
p sub j times new sub
j times that constant.
Here we have the p sub
j times the new sub j
divided by that constant.
And that's equal to this sum
here over all i divided by the
same constant.
So the constant cancels out.
Namely, we left out that term
here, but that term is on this
side, and it's on this side.
So we have this equation here.
If you remember, I can't
remember, but you being
younger can perhaps remember.
But when we were dealing with
a sample time approximation,
if you leave the deltas out,
this is exactly the equation
that you got.
It's a nice equation.
It says that the rate at which
transitions occur out of state
i, the rate at which transitions
occur out of state
i, out of state j, excuse me,
is p sub j times new sub j.
Here's the holding time, and
there's also the probability
of being there.
Excuse me.
Let's be more clear
about that.
I'm not talking about given
you're in state j, the rate at
which you get out of state j.
I'm talking about the rate at
which you're in state j and
you're getting out of state j.
If you could make sense
out of that.
That's what this is.
This quantity here is the
overall rate at which you're
entering state j.
So these equations sort of
have the same intuitive
meaning as these equations
here do.
And then if you solve this
equation in the same way,
what's that doing?
Oh.
This gets you pi sub j in
terms of the p sub j's.
So there's a very nice symmetry
about this set of equations.
The p sub j's are found for the
pi sub j's in this way.
The pi sub j's are found from
the p sub j's by this same
sort of expression.
The theorem then says if the
embedded chain is positive
recurrent, and the sum of pi
i over new i is less than
infinity, then this equation
has a unique solution.
In other words, there is a
solution to the steady state
process equations.
And pi sub j and p sub j are
related by this, and by this.
If you know the pi sub j's, you
can find the p sub j's.
If you know the p sub j's, you
can find the pi sub j's.
There's a fudge factor, and the
sum of pi sub i over new
sub i is equal to sum of
p sub j times new sub j
to the minus 1.
This equation just falls out
of looking at this equation
and this equation.
I'm not going to do that here,
but if you just fiddle with
these equations a little bit,
that's what you find.
I think graduate students
love to push equations.
And if you push these equations,
you will rapidly
find that out.
So there's no point
to doing it here.
OK.
You can do the opposite
thing, also.
If the steady state process
equations are satisfied, and
the p sub j's are all greater
than zero, and the sum of the
p sub j's are equal to 1.
And if these equations are less
than infinity, this is
just by symmetry with
what we already did.
Then pi sub j has to be equal
to p sub j times new sub j
divided by this sum.
And this gives the steady
state equations for the
embedded chain.
And this shows that the embedded
chain has to be
positive recurrent, and says
that you have to be
able to go both ways.
So we already know that if you
can solve the steady state
equations for the embedded
chain, they have to be unique,
the probabilities all
have to be positive.
All those neat things for
accountable state and Markov
chains hold true.
This says that if you can solve
that virtually identical
set of equations for the
process, and you get a
solution, and the sum here is
finite, then in fact you can
go back the other way.
And going back the other way,
you know from what we know
about embedded chains that
there's a unique solution.
So there has to be a unique
solution both ways.
There has to be positive
recurrence both ways.
So we have a complete
story at this point.
I mean, you'll have to spend a
little more time putting it
together, but it really
is there.
If new sub j is bounded over
j, then the sum over j of p
sub j, new sub j is less
than infinity.
Also, the sample time
chain exists
because this is bounded.
It has the same steady
state solution as the
Markov process solution.
In other words, go back and look
at the solution for the
sample time chain.
Drop out the delta, and what
you will get is this set of
equations here.
If you have a birth death
process, it's a birth death
process for both the Markov
process, and also for the
embedded chain.
For the embedded chain,
you know that what you
have to do to get--
for a birth death chain, you
know an easy way to solve the
steady state equations for the
chain are to say transitions
this way equal transitions
this way.
It's the same for the process.
The amount of time that you
spend going this way is equal
to the average amount of time
you spent going this way.
So it says for a birth death
process, p sub i times q sub
i, i plus one.
That's an i there, is equal to
p sub i plus 1 times the
transition probability from
i plus 1 back to i.
So this symmetry exists
almost everywhere.
And then if the sum of p sub
j, new sub j is equal to
infinity, that's the bad case.
These equations say that
pi sub j is equal to 0
everywhere.
This is sort of the dual
of the situation we
already looked at.
In the case we already looked
at of the lazy or rattled
server and the discouraged
customers, eventually the rate
at which service occurred
went to 0.
This situation is a situation
where as far as the embedded
chain is concerned, it thinks
it's transient.
As far as the process is
concerned, the process thinks
it's just fine.
But then you look at the
process, and you find out that
what's happening is that an
infinite number of transitions
are taking place in
a finite time.
Markov process people call these
irregular processes.
Here's a picture of it
on the next slide.
Essentially, the embedded chain
for a hyperactive birth
death chain.
As you go to higher states, the
rate at which transitions
take place gets higher
and higher.
And for this particular example
here, you can solve
those process equations.
The process equations
look just fine.
This is where you have to be
careful with Markov processes.
Because you can solve these
Markov process equations, and
you get things that look fine,
when actually there isn't any
steady state behavior at all.
It's even worse than the
rate going to zero.
When the rate goes to infinity,
you can have an
infinite number of transitions
taking place in a finite time.
And then nothing happens.
Well, I don't know whether
something happens or not.
I can't visualize what happens
after the thing has exploded.
Except essentially, at
that point, there's
nothing nice going on.
And you have to say that even
though the process equations
have a steady state solution,
there is no steady state in
terms of over the long period of
time, this is the fraction
of time you spend in state j.
Because that's not the
way it's behaving.
OK.
I mean, you can see this
when you look at
the embedded chain.
The embedded chain
is transient.
You're moving up with
probability 0.6.
You're moving down with
probability 0.4.
So you keep moving up.
When you look at the process in
terms of the process with
the transition rates q sub ij,
the rates going up are always
less than the rates
going down.
This is because as you
move up in state,
you act so much faster.
The transition rates are higher
in higher states, and
therefore the transition rates
down are higher, and the
transition rate down from state
2 to state 1 is bigger
than the transition right
up from i to i plus 1.
And it looks stable, as far as
the process is concerned.
This is one example where you
can't look at the process and
find out anything from it
without also looking at the
embedded chain, and looking at
how many transitions you're
getting per unit time.
OK, so that's it.
Thank you.